learning to drive opens the door to
independence but for many that's being
stalled
a build-up of cancelled tests from last
year is making it almost impossible to
book one this year
it's really
frustrating you how i say because the
students are test ready and there's no
dates another six to eight months one of
my students she just called me an hour
ago
her theory expiring in five days and she
is literally test ready and she was
crying over the phone i felt that so bad
but what can you do
yeah yes the indicator indicator and
we're going to correct that this time
for learners passing could offer freedom
and safety
i want to drive more for independence
and just to be able to get out when i
can
not having to rely on public transport
taxis and ubers and so forth and a lot
of things that are happening that you
hear in the news with these young girls
i just want to be safe
and i think lockdown taught me that i
need to drive because i couldn't get to
a to b
the backlog of driving tests stands at
around 440 000.
the average waiting time in the uk is 14
weeks
in the worst affected areas it's at
least 24 weeks
to tackle the backlog driving examiners
have been asked to add an extra test a
day to their schedule they voted against
that idea and have planned to hold a
two-day strike
the union representing examiners says
it's unsafe to conduct eight tests a day
rather than seven
to do that they're reducing the time
available for a test
and we have a number of problems with
that seven tests a day is already raised
very very stressful
these are difficult jobs
that require a great deal of skill
people need to be alert and as we all
know it can be quite dangerous taking
people out onto the road
the eight test proposal
the agency has already been told by an
independent firm they should not bring
it in at the moment because they don't
feel it is safe
and therefore our members the ones who
will be doing the tests are absolutely
opposed to being forced to do more in a
day which they think is less safe and
actually will give less value for money
for the candidate taking the test
excellent
increasing daily tests could unlock an
extra 5 000 exams a month for learners
waiting in the queue
while they're in that queue they're
racking up costs by paying for extra
lessons and it's a frustrating barrier
in the road to freedom
jeremiah walker sky news